matin si la chine et l'atelier du monde
l'inde a fait le pari d'être le bureau
du monde elle a investi dans l'industrie
de services l'informatique la téléphonie
du coup la croissance est en forte
hausse +9 % et les classes moyennes
peuvent enfin consommer reportage à
bangalore arnauld miguet fabrice launay
s'il est une ville qui symbolise le
réveil de l'éléphant l'incroyable
dynamisme de l'unss et bangalore toutes
les entreprises high tech qui ont pignon
sur rue il y en a ici 325 indienne
américaine française aussi bengalore
c'est le royaume de la délocalisation
des call center et autres services
informatiques le savoir c'est la
richesse cet adage l'inde seul est
appliquée dans les années 90 en misant
tout sur la technologie fait mieux ces
jeunes gens sont l'avenir de l'un des
cas grâce aux technologies de
l'information
des secteurs comme l'hôtellerie
l'immobilier les transports sont en
pleine croissance dans le pays y compris
ennahdha bangalore royaume des
ingénieurs managers et informaticiens un
habitant sur trois travaillent dans
l'économie du savoir comme ce jeune
couple ils n'ont pas 30 ans gagne 4000
euros par mois divia et rage ont un
pouvoir d'achat bien supérieur à celui
de beaucoup de français et il ne se
refuse rien ou presque
travaillant la nuit comme la moitié des
employés du secteur
ils ont donc toutes leurs après-midi
deux semaines pour faire des emplettes
dans ses centres commerciaux qui se
multiplient
il ya dix ans je n'aurais jamais pensé
pouvoir lui offrir une montre comme
celle là aujourd'hui elle en a toute une
collection ici tout a changé
jamais je n'aurais cru non plus il ya
dix ans pouvoir m'acheter une maison
maintenant on en a deux cette classe
moyenne forte de 50 millions de
consommateurs n'hésitent plus à acheter
à crédit par carte bleue ça aussi c'est
nouveau en inde l'inde est à l'image de
cette société de services pour
téléphones portables chemin elle a
racheté il ya six mois une entreprise
française
arnaut daniel est désormais entre des
mains indienne et s'en félicite dans
trois ans on prévoit ici 500 millions
d'abonnés
pour nous c'est comme si on pouvait
adresser à la fois toute l'europe et
tous les états unis
au lieu de faire un million de dollars
hier on va en faire 10 demain donc pour
nous c'est fabuleux
l'économie indienne avance au rythme
d'un cheval lancé au galop grâce au
secteur des hautes technologies
un secteur qui pourrait propulser l'inde
au rang de troisième puissance
économique mondiale
d'ici 2040 nouvelle créée